nous sommes aujourd'hui en indre et
loire et plus exactement à amboise bien
connu pour ses maisons troglodytes mais
aussi son château aujourd'hui la balade
se passe sous nos pieds dans ce que l'on
appelle les greniers de césar pour
autant les gaulois et les romains
n'aurait pas fréquenté ces galeries les
historiens date ce site d'il ya neuf
siècles une balade réalisé avec charlie
krief lawrence bories et leur envolée
[Musique]
je vais vous faire découvrir les
merveilleux grenier de césar un peu
difficile a ouvert toujours c'est le
poids des années qui fait son office
et nous voilà dans la cathédrale de
tuffeau d'accord t'as bu le grenier de
césar
[Musique]
on parle de 12 cents pour la pour la
construction en tout cas été commencé à
creuser un doux sens et pourtant on a
retrouvé des vestiges romains et gaulois
ça parce qu'en fait le plateau qui au
dessus des greniers a longtemps et
habité et notamment en -52 avant
jésus-christ ou des garnison romaine
était en position ici donc c'est pour ça
qu'il ya eu un doute sur la datation
vraiment de la construction de ce site
mais ce n'est pas du tout le cas on est
c'est sûr et certain que c'est vraiment
448 que les décidé au grenier ont été
conçus comme ça comme on les connaît
aujourd'hui
alors pourquoi les greniers de césar
c'est quoi la save est parti un petit
peu du mythe c'est un nom qui est resté
dans l'histoire comme ça vers le xviiie
siècle au 19e siècle beaucoup de
personnes se sont intéressées à ce site
mais c'est sur les batailles
d'historiens c'est toujours compliqué
quand il ya peu d'informations sur un
site de trouver des choses vraiment
exact
donc ce nom a été donné par ce que à une
époque on était persuadé que ça a été
construit sous l'époque de césar
c'est quoi les dimensions de ce site y
en a deux c'est ça y est alors qu'avant
il ya deux caves parallèle ici au niveau
du niveau 2 la grande cave en dessous
donc de 90 mètres de long une cave
enfin un niveau supérieur ici dont je
parlais qu'il faut à peu près une
cinquantaine de mètres de long et les
fameux stylo que nous allons aller voir
tout au fond ces quatre silos totalement
identiques ont stocké le grain est bien
allons-y donc les 106 fait dans la
deuxième salle et qui est parallèle à
celle ci et qui est totalement identique
je pars du fameux grenier qui sont juste
au fond attention à la tête ici chez moi
le plafond est bas très bas
c'est donc ça les silos exactement on
est tous leurs sens alors pourquoi il
fallait leur sens en étant entreposés
des denrées ici alors du blé en épi en
fait c'était une grange dimière donc la
dîme été payée au roi et à l'église st
10 % des récoltes
j'étais le lieu de stockage 2
[Musique]
et
et je suis avec clémence bouriaud de
l'office de tourisme de d'amboise alors
nous l'avons vu il ya beaucoup de sites
troglodytes ici dans le val de loire le
grenier de césar en fait partie mais
qu'est ce qu'il fait cette spécificité
du grenier de césar alors la première
spécificité que vous avez vues si vous
voulez visiter c'est son architecture
grandiose quand on rentre on a vraiment
une et un aspect de grandeur donc ça
c'est vraiment le physiquement c'est un
très beau lieu son aspect unique aussi
réside dans le fait qu'on ait des silos
troglodytiques tuffeau et briques unique
en france
et puis ce qui fait sa spécificité
également c'est le fait que ce soit un
lieu privé dans un au sein d'un domaine
privé et que l'on ne visite que très
ponctuellement dans l'année c'est pas un
lieu ouvert au public tous les jours
dans l'année on ne visite que très
ponctuellement donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui en face à la rareté en fait
son exception alors les sites
troglodytiques son unique en france ici
en bord de loire est ce qu on sait
pourquoi on ne trouve ça qu'ici
alors oui bords de loire bord de chair
et la roche le tuffeau ici le coteau a
été très creuse et particulièrement à
l'époque de la renaissance pas seulement
mais particulièrement pour construire
les maisons et construire les fameux
châteaux manoirs on est sur une roche
tendre facile à extraire et donc on a
creusé le coteau un petit peu partout en
val de loire et en val de cher pour ses
châteaux les greniers de césar c'est un
site troglodytique mais il y en a
beaucoup d'autres dans la région et
particulièrement en bord de loire
exactement maintenant dans les troglos
ce sont ces ça peut être devenus des
vignobles des caves à vin puisqu'il ya
une belle contre bonne consommation
pardon dans les dents les troglos ce
sont aussi des sites touristiques tels
que les greniers teaser convient de voir
tel que les caves du huard qui sont tout
près d'ici
un troglos que l'on visite autour d'une
expérience sensorielle autour des vins
donc si on veut visiter les greniers de
césar il faut passer par l'office de
tourisme puisque c'est exclusif et
unique seulement cet été exactement cet
été on propose des visites guidées au
grain et de césar une fois par semaine
le vendredi et puis on les reprendra
également pendant les journées du
patrimoine et bien quant à nous nous
nous retrouvons demain pour une nouvelle
visite souterraine du patrimoine de la
région centre val de loire